last night our country fell victim to a
brutal terrorist attack once again as a
result I have just chaired a meeting of
the government's Emergency Committee and
I want to update you with the latest
information about the attack shortly
before 10 past 10:00 yesterday evening
the Metropolitan Police received reports
that a white van had struck pedestrians
on London Bridge it continued to drive
from London Bridge to Borough Market
where three terrorists left the van and
attacked innocent and unarmed civilians
with blades and knives all three were
wearing what appeared to be explosive
vests but the police have established
that this clothing was fake and worn
only to spread panic and fear as so
often in such serious situations the
police responded with great courage and
great speed armed officers from the
Metropolitan Police and the City of
London police arrived at Borough Market
within moments and shot and killed the
three suspects the terrorists were
confronted and shot by armed officers
within eight minutes of the police
receiving the first emergency call seven
people have died as a result of the
attack in addition to the three suspects
shot dead by the police 48 people are
being treated in several hospitals
across London many have life-threatening
conditions on behalf of the people of
London and on behalf of the whole
country I want to thank and pay tribute
to the professionalism and bravery of
the police and the emergency services
and the courage of members of the public
who defended themselves and others from
the attackers and our thoughts and
prayers are with the victims and with
their friends families and loved ones
this is as we all know the third
terrorist attack Britain has experienced
in the last three months
in March a similar attack took place
just around the corner on Westminster
Bridge two weeks ago the Manchester
Arena was attacked by a suicide bomber
and now London has been struck once more
and at the same time the security and
intelligence agencies and police have
disrupted five credible plots since the
westminster attack in march in terms of
their planning and execution the recent
attacks are not connected but we believe
we are experiencing a new trend in the
threat we face as terrorism breeds
terrorism and perpetrators are inspired
to attack not only on the basis of
carefully constructed plots after years
of planning and training and not even as
lone attackers radicalized online but by
copying one another and often using the
crudest of means of attack we cannot and
must not pretend that things can
continue as they are things need to
change and they need to change in four
important ways first while the recent
attacks are not connected by common
networks they are connected in one
important sense they are bound together
by the single evil ideology of Islamist
extremism that preaches hatred so
division and promotes sectarianism it is
an ideology that claims our Western
values of freedom democracy and human
rights are incompatible with the
religion of Islam it is an ideology that
is a perversion of Islam and a
perversion of the truth defeating this
ideology is one of the great challenges
of our time but it cannot be defeated
through military intervention alone it
will not be defeated through the
maintenance of a permanent defensive
counterterrorism operation however
skillful its leaders and practitioners
each will only be defeated when we turn
people's minds away from this violence
and make them understand that our values
pluralistic British values are superior
to anything offered by the preachers and
supporters of hate second we cannot
allow this ideology the safe space it
needs to breed yet that is precisely
what the Internet and the big companies
that provide internet-based services
provide we need to work with allied
democratic governments to reach
international agreements that regulate
cyberspace to prevent the spread of
extremists and terrorism planning and we
need to do everything we can at home to
reduce the risks of extremism online
third while we need to deprive the
extremists of their safe spaces online
we must not forget about the safe spaces
that continue to exist in the real world
yes that means taking military action to
destroy Isis in Iraq and Syria but it
also means taking action here at home
while we have made significant progress
in recent years there is to be frank far
too much tolerance of extremism in our
country so we need to become far more
robust in identifying it and stamping it
out across the public sector and across
society that will require some difficult
and often embarrassing conversations but
the whole of our country needs to come
together to take on this extremism and
we need to live our lives not in a
series of separated segregated
communities but as one truly United
Kingdom forth we have a robust
counterterrorism strategy that has
proved successful over many years but as
the nature of the threat we face becomes
more complex more fragmented more hidden
especially online the strategy needs to
keep up so in light of what we are
learning about the changing threat we
need to review Britain's
counterterrorism strategy to make sure
the police and
security services have all the powers
they need and if we need to increase the
length of custodial sentences for
terrorism related offenses even
apparently less serious offenses that is
what we will do since the emergence of
the threat from Islamist inspired
terrorism our country has made
significant progress in disrupting plots
and protecting the public but it is time
to say enough is enough
everybody needs to go about their lives
as they normally would our society
should continue to function in
accordance with our values but when it
comes to taking on extremism and
terrorism things need to change as a
mark of respect the two political
parties have suspended our national
campaigns for today but violence can
never be allowed to disrupt the
democratic process so those campaigns
will resume in full tomorrow and the
general election will go ahead as
planned on Thursday as a country our
response must be as it has always been
when we have been confronted by violence
we must come together we must pull
together and United we will take on and
defeat our enemies